Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab podcast. And uh,
before we really get rolling and just want to say one thing,
we're going to be in la next week, May 8th, ninth and 10th are,
we're going to be at the Royce Theater for three nights, uh,
with our live show in the dark, which includes Paul libelist and dance troupe,
the singer Songwriter Tau Win, and uh, the comedian Demitri Martin.
Awesome lineup.
You can still get tickets at radiolab.org/in the dark folks who've seen this
show. Tell your La peeps to come check it out. Yeah. Uh,
I don't know what we're doing today. So you, you go, well,
cause here's what we're doing.
Maybe six years ago I had just returned to national public radio and, uh,
and for the first story I did, we just put that in context.
I mean you started national public radio started kind of started near the
beginning and then you went away to do great things on TV for 23 years.
I was missing and then I came back again. Yeah. Okay. So where am I pop back?
I brought this puzzle back with me. It was, it was about motherhood actually.
And uh, it's, well, you'll see,
why don't I just play you the piece that I aired back in, Gosh, 2006,
2000 2006.
It's another time in Paris. Robert Krulwich has the story.
For years it was thought as soon as a baby is conceived,
once it starts to grow inside a mom, it gets its own very private space.
There is,
there's a placenta and placenta was thought to be a fairly impenetrable barrier.
So says Dr. Kirby Johnson of Tufts University,
the baby and its cells stay on the baby's side.
The mommy cells stay on the mommy side and nature keeps them separate until
time to go. The surprise,
when scientists at Tufts took blood from ordinary pregnant moms, we would find,
for example, in a teaspoon of blood, dozens,
perhaps even hundreds of cells from the baby, from the baby.
So baby cells were slipping out of the placenta into the moms.
But because babies do have different genes,
one would expect them to be attacked fairly rapidly.
You would expect them to be cleared within hours if not days.
What we've found is that that is not the case. Not Anywhere near the case.
It turns out that baby cells stay in their mom's, not for days or weeks,
but for decades, four to five decades following the last pregnancy,
so 40 years after conception,
that son or daughter who can now be a middle aged pharmacist or something.
Yet they're fetal cells.
Their baby cells are still floating around inside the mother. Yes.
Even his 60 year old mother's 70 80 perhaps 90 year old women.
You sure this? Absolutely. Yeah.
These cells last essentially forever in the mouth in the mom and says,
Carol Art Lit who studies fetal cells at Thomas Jefferson University in
Philadelphia. Even if a woman has a miscarriage or an abortion,
even if there is no baby,
the cells of an unborn child will stay in the mother for decades,
but why? What exactly are they doing in there for years and years and years?
Yeah, that's a good question. Well, one early hypothesis,
and it's not the nicest ideas as Kirby Johnson,
is that certain auto immune diseases such as Lupus,
rheumatoid arthritis, Scleroderma, are much more common in women than men.
And that's one component of the hypothesis is that this prevalence in women is
due to fetal cells. So later in life, when the mother's joints inflame,
maybe it's her fetal cells, her own Bibi's taken a poke at her.
In fact, Kirby's mom did have an autoimmune disease.
It was a bad one for awhile. Kirby thought, well, his cells were responsible.
So I apologized immediately and said, well,
there's nothing much I can do about it. Yeah, but it's like stopping Kirby.
But you know what? I was always doing that to my mother.
How always causing problems. And it was just another on the long line of,
of those kinds of things.
But happily the folks at Tufts proposed an alternative,
a second theory to explain what fetal cells are doing in the moms. Well,
theory number two is the polar opposite of theory, number one. Yep.
Good fetal cell hypothesis proposes that the son or daughter cells stay in mom,
not to hurt her, but to protect,
defend and repair her for the rest of her life whenever she gets seriously ill.
And that's a more attractive idea.
It's such a personal thing and it does touch the heartstrings of even the most
hard nosed research scientist. But they all have mothers,
but they all have mothers and happily they now have evidence more and more
evidence as Kirby Johnson. But it looks like the good hypothesis may be correct.
For example, here's a case. Well,
this was a woman who came into a neighboring hospital in Boston with symptoms of
hepatitis.
She was an intravenous drug user and she had had five conceptions.
You'd had one child, two miscarriages, two abortions,
that's five in all she could be carrying there for a lot of fetal cells.
And they examined her and in the process she had a liver biopsy and the doc
said, well,
why don't we send her liver to the lab to see if there are any fetal cells
gathering where she's got trouble. And when they looked,
we found hundreds and hundreds of fetal cells.
Normally they'd expect five or 10 cells, but this was a very large,
we cited literally sheets of cells,
whole areas that seemed to be normal,
meaning that those fetal cells had gathered at the liver and like stem cells.
They just turned themselves in this case, into healthy liver cells.
And most interestingly,
this woman did not desire to have any further treatment done. In fact,
she wanted to get back to her normal life and be left alone.
And so she left the hospital with hepatitis. But when they checked months later,
they learned that she is completely healthy, no signs of,
of further liver damage. So no medical intervention,
but just a huge number of her babies fetal cells.
Could that lead you to think the poetic thought that she was safe by her kids?
We want to think that good. I know you do. Um,
there it's the most likely obser explanation.
But in science there is such a thing as a too dangerously beautiful idea.
That's right. Right. If,
and and we say the same thing to ourselves because it shows such a basic
wonderful thing,
but it has to be right and we can't be led astray by our own desire for,
for it to be true.
So they are systematically testing the good hypothesis and the bad hypothesis.
All these ideas on laboratory mice and when they see mother mice with all kinds
of diseases, infectious disease, cancer, ovarian cancer, endometrial cancer,
cervical cancers, we find fetal cells there.
We know that fetal cells don't over and over and over and over and over and over
suggesting that fetal cells regularly rushed to the places where they're needed
in the mom and says, Carol Art Lit.
There's a lot of evidence now starting to come out that these cells may actually
be repairing tissues
that is protecting the mom.
While the other hypothesis that fetal cells hurt the moms, they're,
the more they look, the less they find the,
I can't recall a single study that's been truly reproduced to verify the bad
fetal cell hypothesis. So while no one knows in the end which way it'll go,
I think that that's something that we're going to see within the next five years
or less so far a sense is building that fetal cells probably stay in mothers for
decades to defend and to protect them,
which increasingly is a quiet constellation to Kirby Johnson because it's now
more likely that his sales and his brother's cells were helping their mom not
hurting.
And even though his mother did die Kirby's beginning to feel differently.
Well, maybe if it wasn't for my brother and I,
she may have passed a few years earlier,
maybe we bought her a couple of extra years of time so she could have a few more
birthdays and a few more mother's days. And that if I can just say that,
that I, there is some way where I can even have the remotest fraud that I had
contributed to the extension of my mother's life,
even if it was a few days that would make all of the years that I spent doing
this research worthwhile. Rapid Krulwich, NPR news, New York.
[inaudible]
hmm. So it's been, um, more than five years. As I said,
since I talked to Kirby Johnson, uh, six years really.
So I figured he might have an answer by quieter there.
Hello. Hi Garvey. Hi Robert. How are you?
I wanted to know what do you now know about what those fetal cells are really
doing? Right? So when we left left it,
you were tipping between two possibilities.
One is that they do some harm or the aggravate conditions later in the mother's
life or the opposite that they help in the mother's life. Right?
And do you now have a sense of which was right? Well,
I think it's more than we
originally thought. Like you would expect it. Isn't that always the case? Yeah,
but,
but what we're able to do though now is more specifically argue for or argue
against one of those different hypotheses.
So here's how he's addressed the question cause this is a completely new
development.
He's working with mice and he's taken the glow from another animal,
comes from some sort of fish, a greenish glow.
The green fluorescent protein exists in nature.
He's plucked it on to the fetal cells of a pregnant mouse. Right, exactly.
So what is that like? Is that if you do a, um,
a tummy scan on a pregnant lady mouse,
can you look inside and it's like going to the movies and see? Absolutely.
It is like the movies, it is shiny,
glowing green and it is extremely easy to see. I mean, yeah, a child could,
could say that all that's green so he can look at the mouse and he can see from
the little bits of glean glow where the fetal cells are.
And we find these cells virtually anywhere we look like the longest spleen,
liver, bone marrow, heart. We even find them in brain tissue,
which will help figure out what they're doing so he can track them. Yes.
And we've read and now that he has tracked him, he says, all right,
what I said before about fetal cells, probably helping moms.
I think that in many cases is still true. If you've got a mom who's suffering,
say from some liver disease or something,
you can see fetal cells doing something there and these cells may be able to
contribute to tissue repair after an injury or chemical or environmental
assault. So these are helpers. Helpers get definitely yet, but,
but unlike six years ago now, he suspects that if a mother has,
let's say rheumatoid arthritis or some kind of auto immune disease where the
maternal immune system seemingly attacks itself in this autoimmune fashion,
now he sees other kinds of fetal cells that seem to be causing a problem.
Their behavior seems to suggest that they are attacking them out,
actually attacking maternal tissue. The go get mommy group,
right? And the unfortunate go get mommy group. Wait.
So there are some kinds of fetal cells that are good,
some that are bad and it seems to depend on what again on like where it is in
the body or what disease seems to depend on a longer and longer list of
variables. So including for example,
who the father was that that matter.
We'll remember every fetal cell is half mom and half dad.
We actually do see differences in the cells that are present in the mother.
Depending upon the genetic background of the father and of bad daddy's and good
daddy you. That is entirely possible.
I think we would say good daddies and less good daddies. But what we're,
is that because you're at a university and you never liked to call daddy's bat
one's a bad daddy, but wait a second,
does he know how to explain the difference?
Like why one dad would be good and one wouldn't be bad?
I don't think he knows yet. Oh,
we haven't been able to quite delineate why one cell may be doing something good
or maybe be doing something bad.
It may be the very same cell type that's might even switch sides.
Possibly could. I mean it's sort of like behavior.
You get good kids and you get bad kids. [inaudible] a bad days.
He got good cells and you got pad cells.
This is getting complicated so the cells can be good or bad.
Depends on the disease, that location and the dad,
but we're not really sure if it was the end of the list. We actually get longer.
There's a number of other variables, the number of pregnancies,
also pregnancy loss, whether it's through miscarriage or through termination,
maternal age. That's another very important variable. So who's your daddy?
How old are you when you're pregnant?
How many times have you been pregnant before? Yes, and many other influences.
It it's impossible to correlate a second. So this is,
so when we got to the poetry part of our interview back then you said to
yourself,
my brother and I either roughed up our mother or gave her a few more,
you know, birthdays, right?
It's possible that one of us had a more positive impact than the other.
I mean there's obviously no way of knowing that,
but any normally inquisitive mind would start to wander to say,
well what if this or under what circumstances you,
my mind is wandering wildly now because when we last and that's all we want you
to do, we want, no, I don't want you to be a much better story. If it was,
if it had been for me, if it had been,
if it had gone clearly one way or the other.
But the story you're now telling me is that you and your brother can now meet
for coffee and you can look into each other's eyes and you will not know between
the two of you whether you helped your mom, whether you hurt your mom,
whether you did both,
whether your contribution was bigger or less than the hap stance of your dad's
genetic makeup and an n, n, n,
n this is getting a much harder to be a much harder story to tell.
It is much harder to tell.
So what are you as the story gets blurrier and Blurrier,
why are you still in the game?
A lot of this is driven as you know by the issues that my mother has or had and
I still have that in the back of my mind and I can't get that out of my mind
that a lot of the issues that my mother had recur in the literature,
what that means is that the diseases that killed his mom are the very kinds of
diseases that show up in his, in his research and, and we,
towards the end we had conversations about fetal cells.
And it made us closer.
And I could share my scientific background in the work that I was doing in a way
that comforted her,
I think to a certain degree to know that I was investigating something that was
directly related to her health issues. And, uh,
towards the end we had a lot of real nice conversations about the work that I
was doing and the, the latest discoveries. And she would always ask,
or the after she would ask how I was, she would say, how was the work?
But here's what look,
I think there's a chance that your fetal cells in your moms sometimes helped in
sometimes hurt. So you're not going to come out the hero.
You might even come out the villain.
Doesn't that SAP your enthusiasm for this a little bit.
At some level, of course,
I would want to think that my cells contributed in some small way to some
improvement to my mother's health.
If I find out that it wasn't the case, well that's the truth.
And as a scientist, I want to find the truth.
Whether or not the truth is wonderful or the truth is horrible.
That's what I want to find out,
regardless of what the end personal outcome is.
And what if the truth is, well, some of the time you helped,
some of the time you hurt much of the time, it didn't matter.
It doesn't. That hurt you a little bit. Can you get up the next morning and say,
let's find out how unimportant I am? Well,
that's, that is, uh,
a very difficult question.
I know if I were to be able to go to my mother,
if I put my best effort forward to finding the truth,
and even if it was a negative or was a mixed bag or perhaps was even not really
much of anything, at least I know what the truth is.
And both as a son and as a scientist,
that would be a value to me. Hmm. I may feel unfortunate that I,
that I wasn't able to do something more than the, you know, the,
the emotional support that I could provide my mother,
but I have to look at it as finding the truth.
Yeah.
[inaudible] so that's where we land. Yeah. Happy Mother's Day. Oh,
that's right. This is [inaudible]. This is mother's Day.
I mean, kind of. That's two weeks before. Yeah.
I don't know that mothers really need a day.
They should basically own the calendar,
but since here we are chronologically near Mother's Day, happy mother's Day.
You're welcome.
[inaudible] [inaudible] you've written about this on your blog, right? I have,
yeah. Yeah. I should say I should. We were, that is a,
it's called Krulwich wonders. Uh, so you just write k, R, U, l, W, I,
c h wonders into any search engine and there it is. And yeah, this, this,
this issue and other things many times a week. So yeah, check it out.
It's pretty good.